das geht ganz einfach hier in
Deutschland es gibt ein Marken und
Patentamt und da stellt so ein Antrag
auf die Marke dann wird geprüft ob die
verfügbar ist dann zahlst du eine Gebühr
von 5 oder 600 €os und
dann wird dein Name geschützt ja wobei
ich dazu sagen muss ich hatte noch einen
kleinen Zusatz gehab bushido ist nicht
ganz leicht
zu schützen gewesen da sich dann
plötzlich die japanische Botschaft bei
mir gemeldet hat und meinte ja bushido
ist eigentlich japanisches Eigentum und
so dann haben wir Hal so ein Deal
gemacht aber ich habe es geschafft mein
meinen Bushido sozusagen als Marke zu
schützen und das ist auch gut so